so today we're going to talk about the
causes of acid reflux heartburn and GERD
if you have these conditions this will
be very interesting okay now if you look
up the actual cause of GERD it'll say
and by the way GERD is gastroesophageal
reflux disorder it will tell you that
it's the loss of normal pressure between
the sphincter and the stomach and it'll
say that it's an appropriate relaxation
of the sphincter which is that valve on
top of the stomach that keeps everything
intact and then if we look at the cause
of heartburn it says that the cause is a
symptom of GERD caused by acid reflux
why if you look at the cause of acid
reflux it'll say well we're not sure but
it's triggered by pregnancy smoking
obesity hiatal hernia so there's not
actually a lot of data or information
about the actual causes of these it's
all about the risk factors it's the
related triggers it is the medications
that you need to be on etc and so what
people end up doing is they end up
managing these symptoms with several
different types of anti-acids you have
the protein pump inhibitors you have the
tums which is the calcium carbonate and
something called h2 receptor blocker
okay all three of these basically reduce
the acid in the stomach okay let's take
a look at the side effects c-diff which
is a bacterial infection
osteoporosis decreased b12 decrease
magnesium allergy reactions heart
attacks and this thing called a chloride
RIA okay
tums gas nausea kidney stones allergies
constipation and this thing called a
core hydrea then we have decreased sex
drive
insomnia muscle pain vomiting
constipation and a chloride RIA Wow look
at that
what is this let's take a look
it's a condition where you don't have
the acid in your stomach anymore okay
you have another condition called hypo
chloride Riya okay which is decreased or
diminished acid in the stomach and this
is basically no acid in your stomach
let's take a look at some of the side
effects okay the Sun affects GERD acid
reflux heartburn interesting decrease
b12 constipation decrease magnesium and
decrease zinc because the medications
are actually causing this condition
which is creating the same problem
alright so what's wrong with this
picture we have GERD acid reflux
heartburn then then you take any acids
which then deplete the acid which then
cause the same symptoms over and over
and we have this interesting cycle right
here so then the question is what causes
these conditions okay is it too much
acid well that's something a little bit
different that's more of a sour stomach
that is more of a acid stomach which can
then lead to gastritis maybe it's just
the fluid is this too acidic right but
but what is the normal pH of the stomach
between 1 and 3 okay I mean this the pH
scale goes from 1 to 14 you can't get a
more acidic fluid than 1 so the problem
is not that it's too acid or too much
acid the problem is with all three of
these you're having acid that is
splashing up into the esophagus because
of this valve problem and the valve is
controlled by the autonomic nervous
system so really we have an autonomic
nervous system problem that's then
treated with an anti acid which then
cause these three symptoms very
interesting so let's take another look
at the cause of a chloride riah okay one
of the causes is H pylori this microbe
actually depletes the stomach acids
making the stomach acid less acid okay
another cause would be deficient
Zink which by the way is one of the best
remedies for ulcers and gastritis
decrease potassium decrease sodium
decrease whole rides okay
unique chloride to make hydrochloric
acid decrease iodine decreased vitamin
b3 so you need nutrients to build
hydrochloric acid also a heel
hypothyroid condition you can have this
condition and any acids can cause this
condition here's the big question okay
if this condition causes these three
conditions then what would happen if we
added the acid back into the stomach and
guess what I've seen this time and time
and time again when you add more acid
into a stomach with these conditions
these conditions go away things like
apple cider vinegar and betaine
hydrochloride are very very effective
apparently there's a relationship
between the stomach acid and the valve
and if the stomach acid is the correct
pH that valve will stay nice and tight
but if you have these conditions make
sure you also understand that you need
to fortify your your your body with
these nutrients right here zinc
potassium salt okay sea salt iodine
which by the way is in the sea salt and
b3 all right guys go ahead and try this
and comment below on your results if
you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos